here we take our life support system for  granted we breathe air that is generated  largely by the ocean we have a planet  that works in our favor because earth is  dominated by water by salt water by the  ocean this is a place that we have to  have to make peace with earth with the  ocean so that we can explore other  places so that we can have a long and  enduring future right here on earth we  need to understand what's going on in  the ocean we need to get acquainted with  ocean wildlife the fish the octopuses  the squids of course the dolphins and  whales the sharks all of these creatures  once you get to know them as individuals  get to see how they behave and how  they're they have social structure they  have attitudes they have faces that's  what access to the sea the experience of  being there a whole new era of  exploration is just beginning so lucky  to be around at this point in time to be  a part of the greatest era of  exploration ever  [Music]